y
[Música]
el primer ministro de armenia nicole
para xinjiang convocó a sus seguidores a
las calles luego de anunciar un golpe de
estado por parte de las fuerzas
militares que hoy exigieron su renuncia
los castrenses se lo consideran incapaz
de tomar decisiones adecuadas para el
país tras el acuerdo que firmó para
poner fin al conflicto de nagorno
karabaj que tenemos las reacciones
avanza una desigual vacunación en el
continente americano eeuu lidera la
lista de los gobiernos que más han
vacunado con seis veces más que todas
las aplicadas en américa del sur países
como haití guatemala y honduras no ha
recibido ni una vacuna y depende del
mecanismo kóvacs para iniciar la
inmunización de sus poblaciones
una versión desclasificada de un informe
de inteligencia estadounidense sobre el
asesinato del periodista saudita yamaha
show que sería revelado estos jueves
este revelaría que el príncipe heredero
de arabia saudita había aprobado
directamente al crimen el comunicado
marcará un nuevo capítulo en las
relaciones entre washington y riad tras
la era song
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias en france 24 cierro a blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos a armenia donde el primer
ministro o nicole pajín yandel anunció
un intento de golpe de estado militar
luego que el estado mayor del ejército
de la piedra de la renuncia de todo su
gobierno el mandatario recorre las
calles de la capital del país junto a
sus partidarios gritando consignas
contra los militares la renuncia para
xinjiang también la reclama la oposición
del país ese que armenia a cediera
territorios tras un documento firmado el
año pasado para finalizar la guerra
contra azerbaiyán en el disputado
territorio de nagorno karabaj los
partidos opositores armenios dijeron que
esta es la última oportunidad para pajín
han de renunciar y lo instaron a evitar
una guerra civil
hago un llamado a todos mis partidarios
y los partidarios de la revolución
armenia para que se reúnan en la plaza
de la republica de inmediato porque me
gustaría hablar con ustedes como saben
la situación es actualmente muy difícil
ayer decidí destituir al jefe del estado
mayor y al jefe del ejército lo más
importante hoy es que el pueblo mantenga
el poder porque considero que lo que
está pasando hoy constituye un golpe
militar y desde moscú rusia país que
sirvió de mediador para acabar el
conflicto del enclave de nuestro
corresponsal de xavier colás con las
reacciones
él cree el bien llamado a los armenios a
la calma estas son las primeras palabras
del portavoz presidencial ruso dmitri
peskov sobre la situación en esa
república soviética no se dice que sigue
con preocupación la situación en armenia
el primer ministro armenio nicole para
xinjiang ha denunciado un intento de
golpe militar después de que el estado
mayor armenio exigiese su dimisión la
cúpula militar pide la dimisión del
primer ministro en protesta por la
destitución del primer subjefe del
estado mayor armenio fue despedido
después de reírse de unas declaraciones
del primer ministro en las que el primer
ministro criticaba la calidad de unos
misiles rusos que usaron los armenios en
la guerra con azerbayán a el año pasado
parece que militares y gobiernos no han
terminado todavía de repartirse las
culpas por la derrota militar del año
pasado
los generales denuncian que la
gobernanza ineficiente de las
autoridades y los graves errores en
política exterior han llevado al país al
borde del colapso
el primer ministro criticado en los
cuarteles en los medios y también en la
calle ha tratado de defenderse y ha
pedido a sus seguidores que tomen la
calle para reivindicar su gestión
el embajador de italia en la república
democrática del congo y su
guardaespaldas fueron enterrados en un
cementerio en el centro de roma días
después de que fueran asesinados a tiros
tras una emboscada en el este de la
república democrática del congo tanto
sus familiares como el primer ministro
de italia mario draghi y otros miembros
de su gobierno estuvieron presentes en
el funeral de estado para rendirle
homenaje a las víctimas el ministerio
del interior del congo culpó del ataque
a una milicia rebelde de la etnia hutu
ruandesa llamada fuerzas democráticas
para la liberación de ruanda
y la vacunación en el continente
americano avanza de manera dispar hay
países como eeuu que ya han inyectado
más de 65 millones de las dosis de los
fármacos contra el cob y 19 pero también
hay países que ni siquiera han recibido
en los primeros lotes de las vacunas en
este informe de maromeros a las
repasamos las campañas de inmunización
en el continente y la desigualdad que
sale a relucir
el norte y el sur vuelven a quedar
divididos esta vez es el proceso de
vacunación que dibuja una frontera
sanitaria y política entre los dos lados
del continente americano
en el norte eeuu avanza con rapidez su
proceso de vacunación en el sur hay
países que ni siquiera han recibido la
vacuna
especialmente desde la llegada de joe
biden a la presidencia de eeuu el país
ha acelerado la campaña de inmunización
ya ha inyectado más de 65 millones de
dosis de los fármacos 6 veces más que
todas las aplicadas en américa del sur y
aunque países como brasil y méxico
también han inoculado millones de
vacunas la cifra se queda pequeña en
proporción a su población en realidad
solo chile y eeuu han aplicado más de 15
dosis de vacunas por 100 habitantes les
siguen brasil y canadá aunque a
distancia méxico y argentina no alcanzan
las 2 dosis por cada 100 personas y la
mayoría de países como colombia o perú
ni siquiera llegan a una dosis por cada
100 personas además hay otros países que
todavía no han recibido ni una vacuna
especialmente en centroamérica muchos
como haití guatemala honduras depende
enteramente del mecanismo kóvacs para
iniciar la inmunización de sus
poblaciones
'cuba en cambio no importa vacunas
porque está desarrollando cuatro
fármacos propios
muchos de los gobiernos han recibido
críticas por la lentitud de sus campañas
de inmunización y aunque son varios los
países que ya tienen acuerdos de compra
con las farmacéuticas muchas compañías
apenas se alcanzan a entregar los
pedidos que hicieron antes los países
occidentales
mientras tanto la población
latinoamericana espera impaciente su
turno en un orden mundial que los relega
a un segundo lugar
y el presidente de eeuu joe biden
anunció la revocatoria de una medida
migratoria impuesta por el expresidente
donald trump que impedía el ingreso al
país de algunos inmigrantes por
considerarlo un riesgo para el mercado
laboral vayan elimino con efecto
inmediato la restricción que afectaba a
miles de migrantes beneficiarios de la
lotería de visas para ingresar al país
así como a familiares de residentes
permanentes entre otros según el actual
mandatario la mediante migratoria de
eeuu afecta a las industrias que
trabajan con personal de todo el mundo e
impide que los migrantes consigan sus
permisos de residencia conocidos como
green card
en mi pronto saldrá publicado un informe
del servicio de inteligencia de eeuu
sobre el asesinato de periodistas
autistas amalia yogui en el consulado
arabia saudita en estambul así lo
aseguró la casa blanca el miércoles el
informe que el presidente joe biden dice
que ella leño mostraría que el príncipe
heredero mohamed bin salman
aparentemente tenía el control directo
de la operación bait enmarca un cambio
significativo en el protocolo de la
administración anterior que se había
unido al príncipe
un cambio de rumbo para las relaciones
entre arabia saudita y eeuu
ya leyó el informe llama al show de la
inteligencia nacional sí lo he hecho
gracias el miércoles el presidente yo
bailén confirmó que había leído un
informe de inteligencia estadounidense
que pronto será desclasificados sobre el
asesinato de llamar a sergi en 2018
el periodista saudita ingresó al
consulado de su país en estambul el 2 de
octubre de ese año
poco después fue asesinado por un equipo
de agentes vinculados al príncipe
heredero mohamed bin salman el informe
original en el que la cia fue el
principal contribuyente determinó que el
príncipe heredero había ordenado
personalmente el asesinato sin embargo
bajo la administración de donald trump
nunca se presentó evidencia ni se habló
públicamente del tema tal vez lo hizo
tal vez no lo hizo no hicieron esa
evaluación la cia lo ha examinado lo han
estudiado mucho pero no tienen nada
definitivo la semana pasada la casa
blanca informó que ya estaba en marcha
un ajuste de las relaciones entre ambos
países con el presidente de byd en
restableciendo directamente la
comunicación con el rey salman a
diferencia de trump que se
alineado con el príncipe el presidente
está adoptando un enfoque nuevo sobre
cómo se relaciona con los líderes
extranjeros en todo el mundo y es
diferente de la administración anterior
eso significa que no se contendrá y
hablara cuando haya preocupaciones que
tenga sobre los abusos de los derechos
humanos la falta de libertad de
expresión de libertad de prensa o
cualquier inquietud que tengas al mismo
tiempo tenemos una larga relación con
arabia saudita los acontecimientos
recientes ya apuntan a un cambio
dinámico en la diplomacia bailén anunció
el fin de todo el apoyo de eeuu a las
operaciones ofensivas de arabia saudita
en yemen después de más de seis años de
intercambio de inteligencia y armas así
como apoyo logístico
hasta aquí el informativo de france 24
continúan con nosotros para más
actualizaciones de noticias wan día y
hasta pronto
[Música]
ah